[موسيقى]
الحمد لله الان الاردن يشهد زخم سياحي
كبير خصوصا في اول ثلاثه اشهر
وصلنا حوالي مليون و200 الف ساح وهذا اعلى
من السنه الماضي بحوالي 88%
من الاردن الان مسوق عالميا هذا ادى الحمد
لله انه صار في طلب كبير على الاردن الان
موضوع رئيسي في السياحه اللي هو موضوع
كيفيه الوصول
توقيع الاتفاقيات مع الشركات منخفض
التكاليف زي الريان اير والايزيجت
ساهم بشكل كبير في جذب نوعيه جديده من
السياح فئه الشباب
اللي بيجوا السياحه المغامره بيجوا سياحه
الطريق والاثار
الاتجاهات الحديثه للسياحه في الاردن الان
عن مركز السياحه التعليميه السياحه الطبيه
والاستشفائيه الان حمدان صار في عنا منصه
سلامتك وعصار في بكجات واسعار واضحه
للمرضى سياحه الافلام عم تاخذ جزء كبير
برضو من اهتمام
ونجحنا الحقيقه في اقناع العديد من منتجين
العالميين تحت مظله وتنسيق مع الهيئه
الملكيه للافلام جبناهم وصطفناهم والحقيقه
قرروا الافلام الاردن
الان في تحدي انه نوجد يعني غرف فندقيه
بفئاتها واربعه خمس نجوم في البتراء بدنا
كمان مخيمات اكثر في وادي رم بدنا فنادق
شاطئيه اكثر في العقبه والبحر الميت برضو
استثمار في المهرجانات
والكونسرت هذا الزخم الحقيقه بحاجه الى
انه يكون مزيد من استثمارات لانه فعلا
الاردن صارت وجهه سياحيه معروفه نتيجه
للتسويق الكبير لاخذته في الاعمال الماضيه